ps4 sales are up for the third year in a
row according to Sony I'm Kate and this
is your gamespot news update for the 12
months between March 2015 and April this
year so nice old about 18 million ps4s
this figure shows that despite the ps4
strong start on the market sales are in
fact speeding up in the same period last
year which was cited as a very strong
12-month period for PlayStation the
company ship nearly 15 million ps4s the
ps4 has now sold over 40 million units
which means it still has some catching
up to do as the ps3 currently stands at
more than 80 million units sold
worldwide as of November 2013 seven
years after its launch Sony's profits
are reported to be 2.7 billion dollars
this year a three hundred and thirty
percent increase from last year while
their operating profits for the
PlayStation division are up eighty-four
percent at 819 million dollars sales
could climb even higher if the rumors of
a newer more powerful version of the ps4
proved to be true although sony has not
officially stated any intention to
produce a new model yeah how many of
your friends own a ps4 now will you buy
the new more powerful one if the rumors
are true let me know in the comments or
come and find me on Twitter I'm at how
not to draw thanks for watching and for
your gaming and entertainment news keep
it gamespot